what a great room yeah this is cool Drew
oh I like it
because you helped me do the pilot of
the show which was a basic sales tape
audition to get the show yes and who was
on the first episode of season two you
yeah
[Applause]
it does
a huge difference
on the planet Earth if that's possible I
it means so much but you were meant to
do this I know but I also think you need
to come back and do movies too well yeah
yes yes
it's
it's funny that you say that because we
did come up with a little bit of an idea
the other day about what a trio movie
could be do you remember what that was
it was based off a TV show oh Three's
Company
that would be fun man that'd be
incredible kind of good but we'd go down
to the Regal beagles
who do you think you want to be more
I couldn't do the short hair uh but but
you can I could I'll do it you could do
the shorting I love Janet she's a real
she's going on
yeah yeah and Suzanne Summers yeah I'm
much more Janet you're much more
Christian okay
Mr Roper I'm not as good
I'm not as good as Jack Tripper I'd have
to be like a Jimmy Tripper well we're
not doing an identical yeah this would
be in the in the vein in the spirit of
yes exactly right that's a big idea
three I love that idea well we'll
Workshop that are you happy the other
night when you know everyone from your a
very this is your life moment yeah
you're right you're right I didn't feel
like I felt them it was amazing at the
Kennedy Center Honors yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
guys we thank you it was it was shocking
it was because I I they gave they said
were they giving me this award and I was
like oh okay I didn't really know what
to feel I I knew what it was but I I I
and I saw the show and I knew it was
cool but I didn't think about being on
it and you you all coming and then when
we got there and everybody was there and
everybody was getting to see each other
it became like oh man it's the best
reunion ever and then everybody's saying
nice stuff making fun of me was great I
love people you know mocking me and
stuff that felt good and brought up but
then I just all the nice things
everybody talked about and you guys
being in my family being there was it
was more emotional than I I expected it
was right it got you right yeah yeah
why we're pointing at you like this yeah
we were very sorry
and also this is like what I do
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's what it's there for yeah
um I'm so hot I think I'm having one of
my first perimenopause hot flashes for
the first time I think I'm having my
first hot flash
I feel so honored
I'm so sorry I think I find do you feel
this
internal heat or maybe I'm just that
excited I think you're that excited it's
a warm hand yeah yeah you got a hot hand
that's good because if it was cold that
would be where he said
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're around Oprah and we did a panel
about menopause
is supposed to come with like a very
heavy like anger mood swing maybe you
can bring that out soon too here it is
thank you